[Musique]
je vais m'y rende bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes arrivé en seconde position aux
élections municipales du marin
la liste que vous conduisez la dynamique
marinoise a obtenu 37 0 6% des suffrages
soit 1294 fois vous êtes à 33 voix de
yvonne fritz qui est arrivé en tête
comment vous analysé ce premier tour ben
voila je d'abord je tiens à remercier
les marino a qui ont porté leurs
suffrages sur la liste de nick mallet
noise mais aussi tous les manois qui ont
voté pour le changement analyse la
situation du pô météo comme la suivante
38% ou l'équipe en place de la
continuité qui soutenu par le maire et
tous ceux qui ont fait campagne pour le
changement obtient 62 boussens c'est ça
la réalité cette élection la lys lm a
conduit ce parent et qu'elle aurait qui
nous a rejoint
au second tour la liste elle aime qu
donc il donne pas de consignes de vote
il a eu sa démo conduite par michel
gonnet qui donne pas de consignes de
vote
en sachant que beaucoup des policiers de
ces délices g20 site et nous soutiennent
totalement grosse deuxième deux
sélections donc pour vous avec notamment
ses comptes 3% taux de participation il
ya encore des réserves de voix il ya
beaucoup de réserves de voix parce que
normalement on tourne autour de 7 9% de
toute participation marin est encore
beaucoup de gens qui sont pas allés
voter par rapport à la situation
sanitaire dont on connaît aujourd'hui le
second tour se passera sur un seul mot
d'ordre qui se dit de la commune c'est
le changement et je crois que ce mot si
le résultat du premier tour 62% des
électeurs malinois se sont prononcés
pour le changement
ça doit ça devrait simplifier très bien
pour revenir à l'aco vide
ç'a eu vraiment un impact sur sur sur
l'élection oui ça a un impact sur
l'élection parce que je vois des amis
proches
l approche du vote ils sont pas se sont
pas déplacés comment ça se traduit ça
veut dire que ce qu'on se sent plus les
personnes âgées qui ne sont pas allés
voter
non vraiment pas c'est en fonction de la
réaction qu'on nous avait par rapport à
la situation il ya des jeunes qui sont
pas allés voter il ya des moins je ne
sais pas les outils à des personnes
âgées qui sont pas allés voter et se
joue là c'était assez ambigu même au
niveau national puisque c'est arrivé on
nous dit d'aller voter le dimanche pour
nous dit que le mardi tout de suite
qu'on va nous confiner donc c'était très
ambigu et je constate qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de marée noire qui se sont
déplacés parce qu'on à 53 % de gens
contrairement à la moyenne de la
martinique très bien alors comment vous
vivez comment vous faites alors campagne
avec cette pandémie
pour ce deuxième tour là comment ça se
passe la capan deuxième taux a commencé
le 16 mars
c'est ça que vous se dire parce qu'on a
des positions qu'on était confiné des
confiné on est en campagne
nous étions en campagne ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que la campagne s'est
pas cependant la partie visuelle qui est
campagne il ya tout le travail de
profondeur de relationnel on est confiné
mais le téléphone fonctionne toujours là
le mail fonctionne toujours
les sms les wasaï tout fonctionne dans
cette période de crise on a travaillé à
en donnant la population des indications
de ce que nous pouvons faire pour une
cette période-là y en a qui ont profité
pour faire de l'électoralisme mais bon
je veux pas m'étendre là dessus ça va
pas le montant de paroles mais nous
avons vraiment dire la population gérer
des besoins par rapport à quelque chose
parce que nous étions dans une situation
assez difficile de peur nous avons eu
très très peur
il fallait il fallait rassurer cette
population est accompagné cette
population dans cette période coup vite
donc je pense qu'on a passé très bien
ces périodes là et maintenant que le pot
ministres le 23 mai annonce que les
élections se font le 28 le 28 juin ben
nous avons préparé de fanny campagne
normale
toul à dire normal savent de quoi vous
avez vous auriez des meetings
les seules choses qui sont interdites
ces discussions de tracts c'est interdit
c'est clairement dit ce que ce que on a
aussi parce qu'on a on a des veilles sur
le plan juridique de tous dans l'égalité
on a vraiment vraiment on est bien en
organiser tout ce qui sort au jour le
jour et aujourd'hui par exemple je peux
vous dire
jusqu'à présent on n'a pas statué si des
projets de loi pour statuer si on peut
avoir deux populations passent
pas vrai ça il assuré c'est des projets
de loi à moi on a parlé de le vote par
correspondance tout ces choses là sur
des choses qui citait rythme et les
mêmes mais pour revenir à la campagne m
vous allez organiser qu à des meetings
toutes les communes sauf pour le
candidat qui est aux marins qui est
contre moi qui veut écrire des lettres à
la population pour dit que les mythiques
saint-élie non les meetings les seuls
meeting qu'ils sont et à 10,6 des plus
de 5000 personnes en salle
c'est ce qui est écrit la loi est claire
là-dessus temps et depuis depuis le
début on sait bien vous appelez contre
10 et le regroupement de plus de 10
personnes
depuis la halle premier s'était trompé
et le conseil d'état est revenu dessus
on peut avoir du rassemblement et je
peux vous dire quand je fais un meeting
le soir on demanda le port du masque est
obligatoire
on respecte la distanciation physique et
autour des mesures barrières
chaque personne qui arrive lia les
produits hydro alcooliques à l'entrée du
meeting même si on est en plein air sur
général sont tous une viande avec
quelqu'un et les personnes sont plus ou
moins pleines dents c'est l'air libre et
chaque personne porte son match donc
aujourd'hui je ne vois aucune difficulté
atelier midi comme ça quand tombe le
font toutes les communes de martinique
sont gento merci josemi ronde